to Gus's only keep in mind if you're
doing more than two you get banned
that's the that's the bad consequence
there that's the bad consequence - here
we go this is the third time I'm playing
is black ah there's something wrong I'm
playing white next playing white next
let's try Eve I've already petrov
Philidor well let's see Mr Lopez is in
town
alright he is in town and let's see
where we go here let us see where we go
from here
Castle b5 Bishop e7 let me go with first
B 5 and then Bishop e7 and do I go
forward with a Marshall attack
I'm retain this pawns options let me
castle and if c3 maybe now I go forward
with the c3 d5 I don't know a whole lot
about it I'm going I'm going to give it
a world though I think d5 takes takes
takes thing on d5 takes takes Knight
takes pawn
see six and then Bishop here give it a
shot this is my first time flying it
all right leaves first time in a long
long while does not suit my style at all
my opponents thinking though this could
be a good thing
eternal chess is thinking they're
crunching the numbers so maybe they
don't know the theory I sure don't so
I'd be nice if they don't okay this is
how this is the marginal gambit takes
takes Knight takes pawn Knight takes
Knight rook takes knight c6 to reinforce
d5 with Bishop d6 to follow and then
Queen h4 trying to while giving up upon
and trying to exploit what the backward
development of these Queen side pieces
currently they have they have all seen
better days than these home squares so
is it going to be taken what if my
opponent doesn't take it and plays d3
instead what do i do then oh okay so so
what
okay well do I just i believe i just
take first is there anything better than
taking okay if I take this rook is on my
bishop takes if the bishop takes I can
recapture my knight is still there to
watch over my bishop I think I first
take is there anything better if there
is I'm just not seeing it so if the
knight captures it's on this guy are
seeing it I'm seeing a way to complete
my development just Knight takes
followed up with Bishop here or is this
worth considering Knight takes Knight
I'm just not seeing anything better than
that
oh hang on Knight takes Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes then there's this I
think I have time though I think I have
time yeah there's some oh that's a mouse
slip that's clearly a mouse slip they
meant to do Queen takes okay their queen
now my question is Bishop e6 or B 7 e 6
or B 7 or do I move my I move my knight
away Knight to f6 create some tension
between the Queen's now that did line to
go forward with the development and keep
in mind there's back rank issues if
white is trying to win a piece in some
lines Bishop takes Knight I believe I
have to take with my bishop otherwise
Bishop takes Queen takes Queen takes
Bishop takes and at the end of it rook
takes Bishop on e7 so if Bishop takes
Knight I have to be prepared to do this
and one might think that white could go
forward with picking up two minor pieces
for the rook but if Brooke takes bishop
in that variation if Bishop takes Bishop
takes rook takes Bishop Queen takes rook
Queen takes Bishop fails to Queen e1
game over so I have available to me c5
and c4 to slam the door in this [ __ ]
but might I be chasing it away to a
square that's even better a better
diagonal might be this one
c5 has my attention Bishop f6 as well
let me go at c5 I want to learn more
about the Queen and what I mean by that
is I want to know where she thinks she's
going can't go here actually she's quite
limited she is very very limited on
squares going here it's a fork going
here I could retreat my knight tempo on
the Queen still backwards with the
development and I have not invested in
this instance it is not an investment of
upon Knight here seems very appealing
c4 I think I want to reserve that I like
moving my knight here I think let me do
that
I'd have to do something here I think c4
and well let's see where the Queen goes
let us see where that queenie goes hmm
okay well can't move this guy well I
could take but I have to be careful of
east 7 I think c4 you may could get a
piece here one day let me do this I'm
probably just rook e8 yep I'm to e8
where's the snake going to go where is
he going to go I have a what well more
long-term if there could somehow be a
position in an end game where the knight
gets here this is a very strong post
have pressure on B 2 and C 3 cap in the
night I could play h6 to stop the bishop
from doing stuff I think this is a good
diagonal this is a good diagonal to be a
nun pointing right at a soft spot f2
when maybe I could follow up with some
Knight move is Knight g5 going to be a
good one
with probably not I'm threatening maybe
Bishop here to bishops on these adjacent
diagonals pointing at the night hitting
the Queen Bishop g5 I'm just looking at
Bishop moose okay so could be worked
into a pin okay Bishop takes if the
Queen takes I play Bishop here and then
I'm gonna end up winning a piece so I
think they're for the pond has to take
maybe my opponent will be going for
getting a minor piece and of rook in
this variation if I play Bishop f5 maybe
the Queen takes the rook and then we
have Bishop takes Bishop which I think
would still be pretty interesting
if pawn takes this is a strong outpost
for a knight can I somehow get a piece
here can I exchange LightScribe bishops
and sink my knight in on that d3 post
I'm focused on this because it's a hole
in the white position I also have
support for it and a knight would just
be incredibly dangerous on that square
holding it in your hand it's worth three
but in this position with this
particular pawn structure having it in
White's territory on that d3 Square is
awesome so my opponent must be chewing
on which one of these two is best I
don't think that that one is best
Bishop here I think there I don't know
no I'm sorry the Queen could go back
here but I think that this is still fine
I think that this is still good because
I'm one step closer to getting what I
was just talking about okay so they are
going with that to take with my knight
they are going for this variation
I think Queen c1 was available so now
okay I'm gonna have to sidestep some
annoying hit on my clean I think I play
just to f8 I don't want to allow this
rook to get to this square I'm going to
do this because it's with tempo and I
have a dark square as a flight square I
want to trade off my rook for theirs
that way that way what that way
it's more difficult for white to stay
coordinated so let me go forward with
this more difficult to stay coordinated
and that's exactly what white wants to
have the coordination between pieces so
now my queen is looking to just do what
she wants to be very active and this
seems like a very active square looking
now at this second rink and I believe
that it's going to be quite difficult to
be defending everything now hitting the
rook the bishop there's Queen check
possibilities to pick off be to the
heart of this structure and these pawns
are quite close to falling should any
one of these white pawns be lost but my
opponent has run out of time okay good
game to eternal chess I think maybe one
of the maybe the first time we've played
I'm not sure anyhow let's go back flip
the board and see if there's something
quickly to take away from this so Roy
Lopez and we end up well I play the
Marshall gambit denoted by d5 there and
it was not accepted instead d4 so maybe
you're really just having to go forward
with this as otherwise it's - you're -
backwards with development us so I think
I think you kind of have to run forward
with this capture the only other move
I'm thinking about is d3 but that seems
like he turns out to be a target I'm not
saying right away but just down the line
developing to f5 putting pressure on the
pond so maybe you're just having to go
forward with the Knight takes Knight
takes rook takes c6 Bishop I mean you're
gonna end up having to defend so if
you're not familiar with this if you're
not comfortable with that type of
pressure black could be having on the
Kings side and working against these the
backward development of your Queen side
pieces what else can you do instead of
c3 you could consider d3 you could
consider
I think age three these are just some
alternatives h3 and then if I'm doing d6
then you could do this then you could do
c3 if I'm doing d6 I'm not going to go
forward the marshal so it you could
consider h3 here instead of c3 and I
believe c3 or excuse me d3 as well but
this this is kind of calling out to me
this is a typical move that you would
see if you're going to run forward with
this c3 d4 idea to eventually prevent a
Bishop g4 move which by putting pressure
on the night it'll make white release
the tension in the centre once this c3
d4 expansion takes place okay that's my
main point I believe out of the opening
and once it does get to this point right
here I think I'm just the better side
well at the very least after this
capture well I think Queen captures it
fine
you could retreat I wasn't seeing this
but you could retreat queen queen seat
c1 if rip takes you take with the night
if Bishop takes you take with the night
I think this is still fine for you
it's a little bit awkward because of the
space that I have on the Queen side but
look at the squares that are available
to you by me having run my pawn all the
way down to c4 during the game I was
talking about well I'd like to get a
knight on d3 but you're that's that's a
bit more far-fetched and most direct for
you you could be making use of d4 not a
bad spot for a knight he can't be kicked
from that square so I think that this is
fine for you actually but playing to c1
not not cashing in here and giving up
the Queen for the minor piece and rook
just dropping back I think is still that
you're still doing quite alright but we
did not have that so with this type of
imbalance my main focus is to just get
rid of your
I am able to do that it ended up you
were down on time but this is quite
difficult to now deal with very
difficult to coordinate without that
other look around already my opponent
was also saying things for the game you
are welcome